the central findings of the
investigation are that the man whose
voice is heard on the recording and on a
second recording from the same fox from
the same conversation that was released
on sunday is mr. sterling and that the
hateful opinions voiced by that man are
those of mr. sterling the views
expressed by mr. sterling are deeply
offensive and harmful that they came
from an NBA owner only heightens the
damage and my personal outrage said
sentiments of this kind are contrary to
the principles of inclusion and respect
that form the foundation of our diverse
multicultural and multi-ethnic League I
am personally distraught that the views
expressed by mr. sterling came from
within an institution that I said that
has historically taken such a leadership
role in matters of race relations and
caused current and former players
coaches fans and partners of the NBA to
question their very association with the
league to them and pioneers of the game
like Earl Lloyd Chuck Cooper Sweetwater
Clifton the great bill russell and
particularly Magic Johnson I apologize
accordingly effective immediately I am
banning mr. sterling for life from any
association with the Clippers
organization or the NBA mr. sterling may
not attend any NBA games or practices he
may not be present at any Clippers
facility and he may not participate in
any business or player personnel
decisions involving the team he will
also be barred from attending NBA Board
of Governors meetings or participating
in any other league activity I am also
finding mr. sterling 2.5 million dollars
the maximum amount allowed under the NBA
constitution these funds will be donated
to organizations dedicated to
anti-discrimination and tolerance
efforts that will be jointly selected by
the NBA and it's Players Association as
for mr. Sterling's ownership interest in
the Clippers I will urge the board of
governors to exercise its authority to
force a sale of the team and will do
everything in my power to ensure that
that happens this has been a painful
moment for all members of the NBA family
I appreciate the support and
understanding of our players during this
process and i am particularly grateful
for the leadership shown by coach Doc
Rivers union president Chris Paul and
Mayor Kevin Johnson of Sacramento who
has been acting as the players
representative in this matter we stand
together in condemning mr. Sterling's
views they simply have no place in the
NBA